[Música]
yo vengo de una familia en donde aprendí
dos cosas súper importantes la primera
vez la enseñó mi papá y él me decía que
todas las oportunidades que llevarán a
mi puerta las tenía que tomar porque si
no se iban y la segunda me la enseñó mi
mamá y eso fue amar la danza
nosotros corrimos con la gran fortuna de
que tuvimos a mi tía martha su hermana
martha beltrán quien abrió la primera
escuela aquí en toluca de danza que era
particular y ella me acoge y entonces
entró estudiar ballet folklore flamenco
hawaiano jazz y realmente no fue hasta
los 10 años que conocí el tap yo tenía
un profesor que se llamaba rodolfo y en
ese momento realmente yo no conocía de
pasión pero sí sabía que la sangre me
corría por todo el cuerpo que el corazón
me latía más fuerte y que sentía como un
nudo en el estómago cada que iba a tomar
esa clase es realmente ahí donde
descubro que esa es la disciplina que
más me gusta desgraciadamente mi maestro
falleció y después la verdad es que
había no había maestros de etapa en esa
época sin embargo durante esos años yo
seguí haciendo mis cosas favoritas que
eran que fueran los amigos de los hijos
de mis papás a la casa y yo pudiera
peinar los maquillar los montar es una
coreografía les montaba a una obra y
entonces hacíamos un show después de eso
a los 15 años entró a trabajar como
secretaria a esta misma escuela y a los
17 años entró a dar clases de ballet
en ese tiempo se armó un grupo de tap y
todo el mundo estábamos súper
emocionados porque iba a venir una
maestra de mexico y nunca llegó a la
maestra entonces mi mamá se acercó y me
dijo no marisa pues órale toda la clase
y con mis tres pasos que sabía entré a
dar mi clase y soy muy afortunada porque
yo heredé de mi mamá la docencia para mí
es facilísimo dar una clase entonces
entré con mis tres pasos arme mi clase
pero salí con una angustia tremenda por
no saber más obviamente iba a seguir yo
con ese grupo entonces en esa época en
donde no había internet me puse a
escribir cartas con timbres postales
para todas las escuelas americanas en
donde pudiera haber algún curso o alguna
clase algún taller
realmente yo ahorraba todo lo de mis
clases para poder tener esas
oportunidades y cuando me llegaba algún
taller o algo de inmediato me iba y fue
así en realidad como conocí a estas tres
personas maravillosas
jenny la gone que tiene una historia de
racismo en el tap muy importante diane
water que es una leyenda viviente actual
y ese rey y sea gray publicó un libro
que se llama show for your feet y ese
pero realmente se convierte en la
herramienta que me sirve para poder ser
autodidacta y poder estudiarla y seguir
dando clases de tap en ese mismo tiempo
yo daba clases de jazz en otras escuelas
una vez llegaron dos chicos de mexico y
me dijeron oye los venimos invitar al
ciclón azteca es una competencia de
baile muy importante hay regionales y
llegan a una nacional y le dije bueno
pues déjame algo para ver de qué se
trata me deja un vídeo con todos los
ganadores de un año antes y en ese
momento me puse estudiarlo tremendamente
cuando regrese a paulo vargas me dice
que pasó entran y digo claro claro que
entramos y yo voy a ganar en ese momento
con esa mentalidad
y con ese esos alumnos que yo tenía en
ese momento trabajamos tremendamente
muchísimas horas pasamos los regionales
llegamos a las nacionales y ganamos en
el auditorio nacional
después me empezaron a contratar en
otras escuelas para el mismo tipo de
trabajo nada más que como a mí me
encanta ganar yo les decía sí sí ok me
vas a pagar tanto solo si gano el primer
lugar en dónde y el segundo y el tercero
no y yo no solamente si gano en primer
lugar me pagas entonces pues ganaba
porque cada vez para mí era una
exigencia mayor era una visión mucho más
férrea de querer conseguir ese primer
lugar y aparte hacer que mis alumnos
creyeran siempre que íbamos a ganar
primer lugar y de verdad que lo creíamos
y lo ganábamos a la par de todo esto yo
estaba estudiando mi carrera de derecho
después hice dos especialidades una en
derecho laboral y otra en derecho de
amparo pero yo no sentía eso que les
cuento que no detectaba que se llama
pasión la sangre por todo el cuerpo
adrenalina mi corazón estómago
y llegaba en ese momento una oportunidad
a mi vida que es un pk para irme a
estudiar fuera y con esta oportunidad se
acercó un muy buen amigo de mi papá y me
dijo ya marisa y por qué vas a estudiar
esto de derecho y no aprovechas esto que
estás haciendo con la danza y que te
está yendo también entonces dije claro
por supuesto hablé con mi papá me he
estudiado artes escénicas en madrid a la
escuela scaena y al mes de estar
estudiando me acerqué a víctor ullate el
director de esta escuela y le dije oye
víctor cuando necesites una suplencia de
teatro tapias yo te la puedo dar a la
semana siguiente cerca a víctor y me
hice hombre de marisa que te hemos
armado y el grupo de profes que les
vamos a dar que la que y yo claro víctor
yo te la doy no hay ningún problema por
supuesto salgo de la escuela de verdad
sin aire me flaqueaban las piernas de
ahí al metro porque realmente me estaba
dando cuenta que a quien yo le iba a
impartir la clase era a mis maestros
llegué toda la noche a preparar la clase
la música etcétera llegó al otro día
imparto la clase al final todo el mundo
me aplaude mis maestros
y esa fue en realidad la llave que me
abrió el poder dar clases en primero y
segundo año de artes escénicas durante
ese tiempo como les cuento que me
encanta montar obras de teatro monte
cats tenía la gran suerte de que víctor
ullate este director estaba dentro de la
compañía profesional haciendo cats así
que él fue a ayudarnos a hacer algunos
movimientos estaba estudiando yo un
máster de maquillaje y le propuse a la
directora que vinieran a hacer su examen
final maquillando a los niños o sea mis
alumnos que no eran niños sino eran
también mis compañeros y así se armó la
obra y fue todo un éxito al siguiente
año estaba también dando clases en otra
escuela que se llama madrid 47 y luego
hay monte four y second street y dos
meses antes de regresarme porque se me
acababa la oportunidad la visa y todo
esto y estaba casada en ese momento
entonces había que regresar y pues me
ofrecían la dirección del teatro musical
para mí fue un momento dolorosísimo
lloré yo creo que esos dos meses
y tomé mi frustración mis lágrimas los
echa a la maleta y me regresé a méxico
regrese a toluca y entonces cuando
llegue y se bola a todas estas lágrimas
de esta frustración y a british stage
triste yo quería que fuera como esta en
a me quería traer todo para que ese
programa de teatro musical y obviamente
la danza pero encaminada a la
competencia que era lo que a mí más me
gustaba en mi mamá me ayudó hablándole a
algunas ex alumnas mi hermana marcela
entré a dar clases de ballet y de jazz y
bianca razón una gran amiga egresada del
virginia fábregas entra también a la
escuela con teatro y canto y me ayudó
subsidiando dos años y medio las clases
de canto y teatro porque nadie creía en
esas clases así que yo a toda la gente
de la danza la metía a canto ya teatro
sin cobrar para que obviamente
conocieran esto y después cuando
llegábamos a la hora final vieran que el
producto era algo completamente distinto
creo la filosofía de ganar no es lo
importante es lo único claro esto con el
background de todos los primeros lugares
entonces cuando creo esto lo pego en la
escuela y todos los que llegaban a la
escuela para pedir informes son los
mismos niños y papás veían este letrero
que decía esta frase así que empezaron
una comunidad importante de papás y de
alumnos super comprometidos a a colgarse
de esta disciplina férrea que cree que
creamos juntos para poder llegar siempre
a ganar un primer lugar a través de la
se verán cya de la constancia y no sólo
eso obviamente esto traía atrás
muchísimos sacrificios sacrificios de
muchas horas de trabajo en los fines de
semana de dejar su escuela de dejar
muchísimas fiestas y esto obviamente no
siempre fue increíble
a mí me trajo muchísimos problemas
problemas con papás que no les parecía y
bueno pues como en todo la puerta
siempre es grande es bienvenido siempre
el que se va a comprometer y que tiene
esa meta fija para lograr algo
así que pasaron estos problemas cuando
yo montaba también alguna obra recuerdo
perfectamente haber tenido problemas con
los técnicos porque yo quería tres luces
más y cinco micrófonos más ya lo mejor
habían llegado con cuatro y esto me daba
tanto coraje y me lo tragaba que me
llevaba al hospital y me hice una
persona tan perfeccionista que a la hora
de que me entregaran los vídeos de las
obras nunca las las veo porque no me
gusta ver los errores y no no todo es
fácil es con esto les quiero llegar yo
me preguntaba qué estoy logrando con
esta filosofía y entonces me di cuenta
que cuando se acercaban alumnas mías ex
alumnas mías que cruzaban por mi camino
me decían marisa no sabes todo lo que he
hecho con lo que tú me enseñaste aprendí
a trazar mis metas soy clara soy
objetiva soy tengo éxito en lo que en lo
que hago gente que haya logrado becas en
el extranjero importantísimas gente que
hoy está a la cabeza de empresas o que
tiene sus propias empresas entonces
cuando empieza esto a surgir es cuando
me doy cuenta que esta filosofía que yo
había dicho hay claro para competir
se había convertido en una filosofía de
vida en donde todos mis alumnos lo
habían aplicado después a sus trabajos a
sus familias
a un punto o un objetivo al cual llegar
después viene a una unión de
casualidades preciosísima cuando dios me
manda a mis dos hijos a fernando y a
isabella y estos dos niños se suben a mi
barco de lo importante no es ganar ganar
no es lo importante que es lo único mi
hijo entonces vengan a tomar el tav
claro ahí están los dos y empezamos a
ganar
y después cuando no tuve oportunidad de
regresar a vivir españa nos fuimos a
alemania y mi hijo fer
a la hora de salir de esa competencia
casi se desmaya y dije no pues mi flaco
no me aguanta el estrés y fer tomó el
camino del fútbol muy feliz no se fue al
fútbol pero mi hija se queda en este
barco de sacrificios y de muchas cosas
comprometidas pero ella es una niña
tenaz muy comprometida que aguanta mi
ritmo porque el ritmo de exigencia es
muy pesado cuando tú quieres ganar o
llegar a un mundial o llegar a una
competencia y sabes perfecto que solo
quieres ganar el nivel de compromiso es
muy grande así que isabella se sube en
este barco y aunque obviamente no así no
está no ha sido nada fácil porque en
muchos momentos
isabella se ha cuestionado no es porque
me regañar a tanto ahorita ella les
contará sin embargo lo que les puedo
decir es que nosotras anudadas hemos
logrado un vínculo impresionante de
unión
y de éxito
[Aplausos]
hola
yo soy isabella y he tenido también la
suerte de ser alumna de mi mami de quien
he aprendido que todo mi esfuerzo amor y
trabajo es para ganar yo empecé a bailar
cuando tenía dos años y medio y fue
porque antes la academia de mi mamá
estaba al lado de donde de donde
vivíamos entonces yo siempre escuchaba
música sonidos pasos y me daba muchísima
curiosidad entonces yo un día me metí a
una clase de tap salí fascinada la
maestra le dijo a mi mamá que tenía
potencial que en algún futuro podría ser
buena
desde ahí yo siempre cargaba mi bolsita
con tap que está ahí al lado para
enseñarle a toda mi familia mis pasos la
primera vez que competí fue en equipo y
ganamos
luego me montaron mi primer solo en los
4 años y también gané como yo estaba muy
chiquita no entendía las cosas muy bien
y aparte de las premiaciones serán en
inglés
yo nada más me quedaba ahí sentada mi
mamá me cuenta sonriendo saludando a la
gente me llamaban y yo no hacía caso
hasta que tenían que llegar por mí y
llevarme de la mano ahí está cuando hice
mi primer solo
no entendía nada
la primera vez que sentí ese emoción y
alegría por el aplauso fue cuando hice
una obra en la cual yo era la
protagonista y vea todos aplaudirme en
ese momento vi que amaba esa sensación
del aplauso se preguntarán si es fácil
porque ahorita se ve muy fácil no pero
nada en la vida que te lleva al éxito es
fácil siempre hay frustraciones y
momentos difíciles como por ejemplo
estuve a punto de no ir al mundial de
alemania del 2018 porque yo estaba muy
mal de mis rodillas lo cual me impedía
seguir ensayando y perfeccionar sin
embargo mi mami como siempre me apoyó me
llevaba mi reacción a hacer mi
resonancia magnética y me ayudó con mi
fisioterapia
aunque nuestra relación no siempre ha
sido fácil porque yo cuando era chiquita
como ya les había dicho no entendía
porque me exigía más porque era tan dura
conmigo llegábamos a la casa y me
llenaba de besos abrazaba pues un día
que platicamos y me dijo que nuestra
relación en la escuela era completamente
independiente ahí fue cuando yo entendí
todo la experiencia que creo que es la
que más me un a mi mamá es la del
mundial de alemania del 2017 yo fui la
primera en pasar de toda la competencia
y en la primera ronda me caí para el
bailarín de tap es una super super es un
súper súper obstáculo llegar a un piso
nuevo un piso que no conoces porque te
puedes resbalar como fue en ese caso te
puedes atorar no te pueden salir sonidos
pase las cuatro rondas contra 27 niños
de diferentes países y al final quede en
segundo lugar llore porque no había
conseguido por lo que ya había trabajado
pero salí y le dije a mi mamá el
siguiente año vengo por el primero como
también habíamos llevado un equipo
ganamos primer lugar me sentí súper
feliz se me quitaron las lágrimas abrace
a mi equipo me puse mi bandera corría al
centro del escenario y nos sentimos
súper felices al siguiente año elegimos
una música que yo siento que me
conectaba muchísimo con ella mi
coreógrafo amarse treviño me puso una
coreografía que iba perfecto con la
musicalidad y mi mamá me puso unos
movimientos de cuerpo y de brazos que
iban perfecto con la coreografía y
alemania- a eso llegamos a ganar me puse
de nuevo
mi bandera corría al centro del
escenario me puse en lo más alto del
podio y no había mayor felicidad pero
sobre todo orgullo de representar a mi
país y ahí se ve resumido todo tu
esfuerzo amor disciplina pero sobre todo
la perseverancia de la frase que mi mamá
siempre dice que lo importante no es
ganar es lo único así que ustedes nunca
dejen de perseguir sus sueños encuentren
su pasión y sean felices
gracias